so what the show is basically about
is to
put a man and a woman in two separate
rooms with a barrier between them and
they're supposed to get engaged by the
end of the series and then they have a
honeymoon and a wedding
and
the point of it is love is blind you
know you're supposed to fall in love
with somebody without seeing what they
look like they're trying to remove
what drives attraction between men and
women and say you guys go and sit
between this barrier barricade thing and
talk to each other but you can't see
each other you can't see what they look
like you can't see if they're attractive
you can't see if they're not attracted
to the tall short fat skinny skin color
nothing you you get nothing it's it's
just having conversations
and there's this one guy in the show who
was uh sharp as a whip this guy would
start asking questions i'm going to show
you some of the clips in a minute to
show you why stuff like this fails
the first point that i want to make here
is that
this really just proves that nothing
matters more than
that
genuine burning desire which i cover in
chapter three of my book if you haven't
read it the unplugged alphas on amazon
genuine burning desire
comes from
attraction it comes from looking at
somebody i've said this many many times
somebody might have a great personality
a wonderful personality in fact but you
can't [ __ ] somebody's personality when
you look at somebody when you talk to
them you're basically thinking like
would guys do it anyway you know we're
thinking okay well what does she look
like naked
sort of thing
um women are also interested in that but
they also have a long laundry list of a
bunch of other stuff too that comes with
that so let me just play some of these
uh clips here and add some commentary if
you guys are listening to the replay
just fair warning i'm going to play
these clips at like one and a half times
speed so if you're already playing this
back at one and a half time speed this
is going to sound weird slow it down
right here uh let me add this to the
stream
and if you have a hard time hearing it
just let me know in the live chat but i
think i got it set up correctly so let
me just play this
reel here i love it and by the way i've
got to pause it every couple of um like
every 10 seconds or so because of
copyright blah blah and sound whatever
it is so i'm going to i'm just going to
pause it through and add some colors for
girls yeah what's your size
i love buying clothes for girls yeah
what's your size
would you like working out yeah not a
huge fan really yep i get along best
with individuals that do work out
this
this guy is awesome he was he was the
only guy in the show that was honest
with
the other side and with the producers
and at the end of the series it was
basically like
i get along well with girls that that
work out you know and he's like you know
do you work out she's like yeah i don't
really work out and
you know here she is so it's
he's clever enough to eliminate you know
things that he knew would not work out
basically yeah i'm just going to put up
on the screen moth because i don't want
the woke crowd to give me a hard time
they can read it but essentially yeah
that's about what i was about to say
next is they turn them into a villain
i'm going to show you how they shame
this guy for
expressing preferences so the next point
that i want to make is it's totally fine
for women to express preferences women
do it all the time on dating apps must
be at least at least six feet tall must
have six pack abs 600 horsepower cars
six dishes in the past it's month out of
a relationship blah blah blah blah and
they you know
you know doesn't have any kids in tow
doesn't live with their mom
must have a job
but when a guy says hey i like girls
that work out it ends up in a cringe
compilation that we're watching right
now and we'll see how a few of these
guys deal with this guy towards the end
will you marry me
this guy's a total sin
so
this fella and this girl um
shayna was her name i just called her
lips and tits during the show because
that's all she was really you know she
was like the eye candy you know throwing
it in the group and this guy and her
she's apparently purported to be
religious and he is non-religious and
they have this
flare-up but that's not why they don't
get together and you're going to see why
in a minute it's simply because um there
is an attraction issue let me just keep
playing this here
as soon as i see her it's gonna be two
hands
boom i already let her know so
this dude went through the entire crowd
and then he ended up proposing to the
only indian girl on the show he was the
only indian guy and they both start the
conversation basically saying stuff like
he goes i only date blonde girls and she
goes i only date blonde guys anyway he
ends up proposing to her so watch what
happens next from here on out
she's within a two mile radius from me
that booty is not safe oh my god hi
okay so
just as a you know aside that's what
genuine desire looks like between two
people when they see each other i mean
obviously they've been having
conversations but
in person
when they met they don't end up getting
married towards them but when they met
they did have genuine desire now i want
you to watch what he does with his hands
because he's obviously into physical
attraction
i'm just gonna do this okay for the
camera up and down for those of you that
are listening to the podcast by the way
these are all available in podcast form
everywhere guys spotify apple whatever
you can always listen to them if you're
driving or whatever but um there's
there's something missing on the
attraction scope of things which we'll
see more of in a bit but just watch his
hands oh my god you're so evil holy [ __ ]
hi
look at that booty
okay
he said booty booty booty over and over
again but he got this right
top to bottom to be at a music festival
do you like being on a guy's shoulders
yeah you're up for the challenge you can
pick me up yeah but um will i have
trouble picking you up
[Music]
will i have trouble picking you up isn't
that awesome very clever right clever
enough to get around here right
um this this one here just just listen
to what she says i mean you can tell by
the way her mouth is open but just
listen to this nonsense
i have a huge instagram following
obviously i have like a lot of friends
that get crazy and i think i'm really
good at these pods because like with my
job i have like five to like 20 people
in my car like at a time
so none of these guys could see what she
looked like but they were all irritated
by her she didn't go very far in this
nonsense
how old are you 33 i prefer dating
younger
so he got shamed of course you know she
says she's 33 he goes i prefer dating
younger eyebrow raise this all piles up
you know towards the end where they all
basically [ __ ] on them are you i'm 32.
you look like a baseball player
this guy's a bit annoying he he's
somewhere on the spectrum he just they
actually casted him real well you know
they put him on the show for a good
reason um
okay so this is towards the end
here at the reunion so let's hear what
they're saying
right about here i think
sorry to interrupt you
this show i don't want to lose the
thought i'm sorry but the show is about
can we just say off the record that you
can't help god sometimes it's okay
if you don't remember today
you seem horrified
uh i think it's when this dude over here
starts ripping into him right here
i can't it's keeps it real no that's not
real man that's just bad it's just
always happening
he's he's basically saying look you know
you can be attracted to somebody's
personality but i need to see her and
there's nobody here that i was attracted
to so they start lambasting him for the
sorts of questions that he was asking
like
hey i like going to music festivals you
like that yeah i like going to music
festivals well uh you know do you like
being on a guy's shoulders at a music
festival oh yeah i'd love that you know
do you think you're up to the task and
putting me on your shoulders uh yeah but
would i have a hard time picking you up
and putting you on my shoulder so saying
things like that on the show got him
blasted towards the ends here what
everyone's thinking at home
i'll say one statement and hopefully
i'll just shut up after that wouldn't
you like that i think we'd all like that
i think we'd all like if i just shut up
after the statement i think we'd all
like if you just shut up no please just
stop now
i'm the reason i'm the realest jared
i've
this this this couple here the black guy
with this other girl
um you're going to watch that one fall
apart because you're not you can't you
can't we can you're not you're not you
came here for all the wrong reasons and
you know that everybody can see how
shallow you are even even this dude over
here
this black dude sitting here as black
girl is is trying to shame him in front
of everybody else and look at the body
language of everybody here right
it's just absurd
this
this this narrative where you can't have
preferences if you're a man and say that
again you can have preferences if you're
a woman you can have all kinds of
standards has to have this income
has to have a nice car has to live in a
certain neighborhood you know it has to
have a certain kind of job you know for
to be acceptable for to be you know
taking this guy out to introduce him to
fan family and friends but a lot of the
women they put on the show like um the
one that i mentioned earlier uh lips and
tits uh the blonde girl that's a
hairdresser she's a hairdresser you know
like what do you bring to the table you
know
kevin the vp of sales is making a
quarter million dollars a year is gonna
put a ring on that at some point and the
interesting thing you know during the
show was
well actually i'll show it to you in the
next clip i won't i won't give it away
just yet uh
you think so yeah i know absolutely
because he loves me for me okay so we're
gonna drop that out
let's pull in the other clip over here
because i got a few more things i wanted
to cover
have you guys seen the show by the way
just in the uh live chat just let me
know
all right share screen
chrome tab
this is the number 10 one
okay
so again
attraction
comes visually you know i mean maybe if
you're blind maybe if you're blind you
know you're going to have to rely on the
other senses but the biggest driver for
attraction for men and women is visual
it's why in my book when i covered uh
dating and how to get the girls and by
the way when i put how to get the girls
that was a joke right um some of you
didn't get that most of you but
um i talk a lot about having a good look
as a guy and how to portray that and how
to use dating apps to communicate that
clearly it's all detailed in the book
now what i want you to pay attention
over here in this first clip over here
for the first little bit is these two
um i think this guy's hispanic this girl
is uh polish and hispanic but i just
want you to hear what she says because
she doesn't really feel it for this guy
just listen up here i'm definitely in my
head i'm very attracted to him
emotionally but physically like
i don't really i don't know welcome to
miz okay but physically i don't know
this guy's
jack too i just want you to look at her
emotionally but physically
okay
this trick is not attracted to this jack
guy who's in very good shape
but she sits there saying that he's not
good enough just just let that set in
okay this is what you're getting off
body language and off exactly what she's
saying telling you she's not into the
guy like
i don't really i don't know welcome to
ms mojo all right let me just skip up
because i got a few time stamps here
uh
150 is the next one i wanted to cover so
okay so watch body language with gender
genuine desire here so
just got shake doing the little size i
already let her know but here on out
she's within a two mile radius for me
that booty is not safe the first time a
couple interacts with each other face to
face is the type of encounter that has
the potential to be cute or cringy shane
and natalie's kiss for example
demonstrates that they need okay we've
got we've got clear genuine desire here
you know between these two as well you
can tell by the body language by the way
they're touching each other this is
important note it of course is entirely
based on
them having a uh
you know like liking each other's
personalities and then they of course
like each other more in person but
beyond that watch what happens need a
little more practice and shake could
have saved his possessive booty grab for
behind closed doors oh my god again you
know dude get shamed you know you're not
allowed to touch her you should have
wait you know waited for it behind
closed doors
here's lips and tits over here and this
is what genuine desire does not look
couples are passionately awkward now
these two
as she comes out she clearly doesn't
have the feels for what this guy looks
like after he's revealed
lukewarm reaction just
notice where her eyes go when she walks
in she's not looking at him
it's really really important to know
while these two couples are passionately
awkward mallory's lukewarm reaction to
salvador also makes us wins it's nice to
see him person oh my god okay hi how are
you see that's that's not genuine desire
right there the last one where they jump
on top of each other not there
boom but if you go back and you see that
you know she's not even looking at him
and she's walking into the room
it's just not there it's missing
meanwhile kyle and here's lips and tits
and uh kyle um i think this guy is in
the trades and this is the hairdresser
and shayna have their own odd first
encounter during which shane like
they've literally just seen each other
for the first time and she's already you
know given him a hard time and he's like
you know looking away and you know can
we just try but just listen up here
keeps her distance and expresses her
doubts i don't like him i don't want him
i don't want to getting caught up in
that man are you willing to try number
eight
dude never ever ever simp for a woman
like that
she's either into you or she's not it's
not like well let's just give it a try
or let's just try again or let's see if
we can make it work
i mean roller said it you can't
negotiate genuine desire it like you
just can't do it it's either there or
it's not there it doesn't matter how
much you like their personality and this
way i don't get these dudes that are all
like you know they'll get on a dating
app and they'll see it like a picture
and they'll tell me they've been
messaging back and forth for like weeks
or a month it's like no dude the whole
point of the dating app is to me like
even if you have a photograph it doesn't
matter the whole point of the app get
their number get off the app
do a little bit of back and forth and
then set the date that's that's the
that's a sequence that needs to happen i
mean i cover it more depth in my book
but that's a sequence that basically
needs to happen you have to meet them in
real life because when it comes to
dating apps i mean women generally have
the
impression that guys lie about um i mean
guys lie about different things the way
that women do like women will lie about
their looks guys will generally lie
about their success guys generally lie
about their height women will generally
use older photography that makes them
look more flattering or from angles you
know that show more cleavage that hide
other parts of their body sort of thing
that may not be as attractive but you
get the idea nah and kyle discover their
religious differences the love is blind
experiment tests whether conversation
alone is enough to find a fiance no i'm
not religious at all
with nothing to do but talk contestants
develop their relationships by
discussing their values and goals shayna
basically describes christianity as a
major pillar of her life so when kyle
says he's an atheist it seems like a
deal breaker yeah the atheist thing
okay so she takes the
proposal takes her like 10 minutes to
answer him these two get together
where's my neck clip 5 15 let's pull it
up here
okay so now we've got the carpenter and
lips and tits here on the honeymoon
because he proposes to her she makes him
wait like 30 seconds before she says yes
and here's the honeymoon scene that i
wanted to show you next hey so i'm a
little nervous for my cervix but he's so
cute number six shayna leaves mexico um
i was looking forward to the first night
that he would seven nights separate
rooms
i don't know if you caught that but she
said to him in a low voice tonight we're
going to spend the night in separate
rooms
again if you have genuine burning desire
for somebody you're going to be intimate
especially after you've been talking
through a wall for a week long and
you've developed a
connection that doesn't involve
physicality you see each other it should
be there when you're able to go away for
the honeymoon you should be all over
each other like a fat kid on a piece of
cake but she's telling him from the
get-go
we're gonna have to sleep in in separate
rooms and this and this guy keeps trying
man he doesn't like these plugged in
betas they don't know they just don't
they just can't pick it up man
considering this couple's rocky
beginnings it's not surprising that
things don't go well when shayna and
kyle arrive in mexico the events that
play out are the perfect combination of
dramatic and cringy which can only be
achieved in reality tv wait wait when's
the last i love how these like you know
female commentary commentators use this
word cringey cringy so much there was
there was a couple other videos that i
was um watching before these ones that i
came across and they were mostly done by
psychologists and it's and they're
[ __ ] hilarious you know they're
constantly using words like cringe but
they also use uh love languages
which we've proven is a colossal lie i
did a collab with my friend paul on my
channel um so you can search on my
channel if you want to see the results
of that but just search for love
languages entrepreneurs and cars you'll
come across it and there's another one
that um had the the personality uh what
are they called the injp or s
you know the ones i'm i'm talking about
and they're commenting on on that sort
of thing the love language one got me
like as soon as they start talking about
that nonsense it's just turn that [ __ ]
off because that's not real it's a total
crap actually eight years
yeah
you're breaking it their first evening
together begins awkwardly with shayna
feeding kyle who's a vegetarian a bite
of her steak dinner i hate feeding
people
that's something you generally don't
want to do i mean okay maybe it makes
for a good highlight reel on television
but
i mean somebody says they only eat meat
you don't shove a salad down their
throat some you know likewise somebody
says they're vegetarian you don't go
shoving meat in their face but this is
what lipstick tits does here i think
it's so cheesy from there it just gets
worse shayna sets boundaries in their
relationship by insisting on sleeping in
another room at 7 40 p.m she retires for
the night could you imagine being uh you
know your purported honeymoon and your
fiance says um it's 7 40. let's go to
bed but you have to sleep in that room
and i'll sleep in this room
telling kyle she'll see him in the
morning so like
take a look at her
you tell me
that she's a virgin
right she's a 30-something-year-old
hairdresser
and she's talking about you know
sleeping in separate rooms and she's got
you know religious you know uh
boundaries and stuff like that
i mean
when you get your lips done like this
lady you're not fooling anybody i'll see
you tomorrow morning
you're gonna go to your room now
it's
um seven oh my gosh early four
in a situation like that just tell her
to get lost you know pack your [ __ ] and
get the hell out of here and he's
sitting there going you're getting in
your room now but it's but it's only 7
40. um but but but
she then packs her bags and leaves
paradise and her feet she leaves on her
own accord beyonce behind the fact that
shayna departs secretly without telling
kyle leaves our jaws on the floor it's
not the same
without trina
the fact that she's not here
a lot of this stuff is engineered again
you know like it's not it's not fully
authentic
um
i think we have shake here asking about
weight
still let's see what that clip
number five shake asks about weight in
the beginning of the experiment it seems
like contestant abby shake better known
as shake is missing the point about love
being blind i love buying clothes for
girls yeah what's your size dude's
brilliant
i love it this guy's red-pilled for sure
he inquires about his date's weight in a
roundabout way that's both obvious and
insulting he develops a reputation as
super
oh hang on this is where she
insults this guy official among the
women
he develops a reputation what does she
call him superficial let's play that
back again he develops a reputation as
superficial among the women
superficial
it's it's superficial when a guy has
weight standards he won't he won't date
somebody that he's not physically
attracted to but again
if a woman has standards for financial
resources looks
height
doesn't have kids
you know living arrangements jobs that
they have sort of thing and then all the
other 300 points that they usually make
as well that's totally fine but a guy
has like one standard i just don't want
a girl that's fat
superficial everybody lose their mind
right
all right let's see what else we got
here we got eight
oh eight eight eight eight eight minute
okay so eight at the eight minute mark
um
the fella kyle the construction worker
whose fiance uh told them to sleep in
separate rooms who also left without
telling him they're now at her parents
house
uh being introduced to the family so
check this out i get along best with
individuals that do work out number four
meeting the families why you get married
now
can you guys see my curse okay so you
can't see the curse so this is mom over
here
fellas one of the things you always want
to do before you're going to deal with a
woman on a long-term basis or make her
the mother of your kids take a look at
what mom looks like just you know
you'll thank me later heads up on that
so no one else gets here
while bringing someone home to meet the
family is so i don't know if you caught
that but what they asked him was why do
you want to marry my sister and his
answer was so nobody else gets you
beta
plugged in beta always a stress inducing
milestone bringing a fiance home after
less than a month of dating is sure to
raise some eyebrows mallory and danielle
both have to navigate awkward
conversation all right let's move this
up a little bit
uh
we've got some talk on the beach we got
lips and tits again now i just want you
to look at shakes behavior
so
this guy's shake
he had genuine desire for talking
between the wall when they met in first
person before i believe he slid his
hands down her back and got
flat
um that that that is where his behavior
changed but just watch what he says over
here
each other and i'm excited to just
connect with you on all these levels all
these levels despite their similar
backgrounds shared life goals see his
body language see the way his eyes are
kind of rolling around not into her
right at all and complimenting
personalities there's one problem
threatening shaken dt's relationship
shake doesn't feel physically attracted
to her she's like the number one hype
girl i could ever ever ever hope for her
upon seeing his fiance he begins to
express a lot of doubt to other people
and finally to defeat herself he
compares her to his height person his
friend and even his aunt but his aunt
there was a video that i came across
that uh called this guy shake a
what do they call him uh
basically a closet racist and um they
shamed him on on something else i can't
can't remember what it was another
psychologist it was this asian girl that
broke down and basically [ __ ] all over
the guy
um what other clips were there here i
think there was one at 1340.
thirteen forty what do we got here
and switch on notifications number one
shane mistakes natalie for shayna you
were my number one son you were my
number one too natalie may bring out the
best in shane but dating in the pods
seems to bring out the worst the realtor
begins the experiment with a playboy
mentality willing to date as many women
for as long as he can
yeah when guys want to date women and
explore their options that's bad when
women do it totally fine rack up your
notch account ladies what could possibly
go wrong
does she like me
jane inevitably finds himself in a love
triangle with natalie and shayna who i
talk to i don't know take a guess no
there you go while juggling two women
who are so in this scene he calls the uh
he calls this girl natalie shayna
because of course you know they
manufacture that you know they put this
stuff together for tv uh that's about
the you know
the
end-all be of all that i don't really
want to keep banging on all these clips
because
it all just kind of boils down to the
same stuff you can't
i don't care if you want to put put a
put a wall or a skyscraper you know
between people whatever it happens to be
you can't get away from the fact that
women may select guys based on their
looks and a whole bunch of other things
success is is definitely
one of the most important ones also you
know women look at guys as far as you
know
they're more concerned with a guy's
future whereas a man is more concerned
with her past what does she look like
how many guys she'd been with is she
attractive you know so you can't get
past any of that stuff by putting a show
together on netflix and hope that it
works out there's only two couples
out of the entire cast by the way
that ended up uh going through with the
engagement and the marriage um that dork
with lips and tits never made it she
basically told him to pound sand towards
the end and actually ended up having a
thing for this guy shane um but uh she
just didn't have genuine desire for that
guy it it really had nothing to do with
the whole
religious um
you know demands that she and she said
her family had because at the end of the
day i mean you take a look at her you
know she's got some miles on the clock
and she's and she's she's not celibate i
mean she's not chased by any stretch of
the imagination absolutely freaking not
but um that's what they try to sell you
on these shows guys you know it's it's
it's manufactured again it's for
entertainment purposes only but
you know when you unplug when you take
the red pill and you kind of see the
code in the matrix and you understand
these things you watch shows like this
with a renewed interest in looking at
the dynamics unfold
and then you know you can't help but to
comment on those dynamics afterwards i
don't know you guys seem to like the uh
video i did the other week on the tinder
swindler thing so i thought i'd uh pull
something out and do some commentary on
this uh joseph jones here says isn't lip
work superficial yeah like lip work boob
jobs i mean push-up bras are arguably
you know superficial putting on makeup
is arguably superficial uh dying out you
know your gray hairs uh you know back to
blonde or uh you know whatever is
superficial you could argue all these
you know wearing high heels so they look
taller so their calf and butt looks
different is superficial basically
it is what it is you know um there's
there are some things that are excessive
of course you know botox and boob jobs
that's you know like sticking a needle
in the lip okay that's one thing going
through surgery you know it's something
else sometimes it's required gravity
does that stuff but i don't know
it is what it is hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forge
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you